thank you members
you've now just received a
set of minutes from the cabinet this
morning i am now going to
pause the meeting until you have an
opportunity to read those
um so five minutes is that adequate
i see no dissension so give it five
minutes and then we'll restart the
meeting thank you
thank you members
i hope everyone's had an opportunity to
read through the the mints from this
morning
okay
um
can i ask the head to pay service to uh
for apologies about him please
chairman thank you apologies have been
received from councillor adam eden
harris henshaw seraphin
kendall
o'donnell
parry and richards thank you thank you
disclosures of interest members are any
disclosures of interest on the items
coming along
no
it's oh yes again thank you
announcements uh no announcement at this
moment
let's try that is it better sorry about
that item five a future relationship
with warwick district council and future
working arrangements to consider the
immediate implications and associated
decisions for revised working
arrangements
i'm sorry about the i think we're gonna
have to make do without the mics
this afternoon
we'll keep going and just see what
happens
okay um to receive any recommendations
from the extraordinary meeting which
you've now had the minutes oh sorry the
overview and scrutiny i apologize uh
held yesterday uh and the
recommendations for the extraordinary
meeting of the cabinet held today
uh chair um i would like to invite
councillor jefferson as a leader i think
his appointment was raised personally oh
apologize council rock point of order mr
chairman thank you very much um
as i noticed uh i i would suggest to
council it might be beneficial
if we suspend the rule about members
speaking once because it may be
such an important issue that uh members
may wish to come back on the odd time i
hope we're not going to be horrible here
all afternoon as a result if we do pass
that but uh i would recommend that to
council and look for do we need a second
for that mr chairman
yes i will please the council jr right
member says it is a request uh it's a
majority vote simple as that so could i
ask all those in favor of suspending the
uh
ability to speak once uh raw please
raise your hands
thank you and those against
and extensions
thank you um
okay gentlemen there was um
more votes against the the record the
proposal than than in favor therefore
the council standing orders will prevail
thank you if i may say council rock i do
appreciate where you're coming from on
this one if there is um something urgent
or
not urgent it's a wrong word uh
important to the conversation
let me know whoever wants to speak and
i'll make an accommodation
thank you
okay i would then like to invite uh
council jefferson
to introduce this report please
thank you chair and i should just say
that uh
my prior arrangement with the chair
because i've got a bad ankle he's
allowed me to carry on speaking sitting
down
so
i mean as he said this report is fairly
simple it identifies the immediate
implications
arrangements for the council
with warrant district council following
the recommendations from from the
leaders of both councils
to end or withdraw the request to merge
i think it's important to state that
uh
at the meeting that mr buckland and i
had with councillor day
and the chief exec of warwick district
council in reality and in practice the
merger ended at that meeting
um
i made it very clear that i was going to
submit a request to the secretary
secretary of state
uh for a deferral on the decision until
we'd had the results of the due
diligence exercise
uh councillor day
thought that if i did that it would end
the merger process uh within half an
hour of the meeting ended the letter had
gone
so the merger process was effectively
ending ended
however
we have to make a formal submission to
the department for levelling up housing
and communities
to withdraw
the submission to create the south
oracle district council
the other thing
we have to
accept that work on the full service
integration of teams across
stratford-on-haven and water district
council be terminated
we also have to terminate work on the
identification
of sharing civic and office
accommodation between the two councils
uh we need to review the constitution
to remove
the joint appointments committee the
joint appointment subcommittee and the
joint arrangement steering group because
they are no longer appropriate
and transfer the terms of reference from
those back to employment committee
uh
the arrangements for the joint
management team are to be terminated
from the 12th of may
and the interim management team
structured be noted
uh changes to the officer scheme of
delegations as a consequence of the
transfer of service functions between
chief ex officers be approved by the
council as shown in appendix 4.
we've also got to note that work
on the joint south warwickshire local
plan and the joint south oregon economic
strategy will continue
and that the existing arrangements in
relation to climate change will continue
so this puts in place everything we need
to do
to
cancel
where it's appropriate
sorry
for 15 years and we'll continue so the
chance we could be louder tonight okay
uh worked
reinventing wheels when perfectly good
wheels already exist
sorry
can you hear me now
good
uh legal services
a shared service
went live on the first of april this
year
uh the new joint arrangements will save
a collective 150 000 a year share
between the two councils
uh
senior officers and politicians have
agreed that that will continue
and i think that is an excellent idea
uh
[Music]
if we go on to the development of the
south warwickshire local plan and the
southwest economic development strategy
we have agreed that that work will
continue
i would say that in the case of the
south oregon local plan
that will be in terms of the evidence
gathering and doing all the background
work as we get further down the track
and it begins to get to decisions
political decisions that affect each
individual council differently
then that may well need to be
reconsidered
but nevertheless that work continuing
jointly he will save
a lot of money originally if you
remember we had 1.6 million in the
budget for work on the
local plan
a lot of those costs will now be
shared
if we come to the joint wasted recycling
contract
both councils are committed to a
contract
with before
initially for eight years for an eight
year period from the first of august 22.
that contract has been signed
um
so that new contract also provides the
introduction of the one two three plus
method of wasted recycling collection
uh obviously because it's a contract
it makes absolutely absolute sense to
continue as planned
pulling out would cost money
stratfor district council will lead on
the contract management and mobilization
of the new contract and will recover at
cost the relevant proportion of these
costs from warwick district council
so in addition to the management of the
contracts
stratford
on even district council's contact
center will continue to support warwick
district council in respect of charges
for their garden with subscriptions
and telephone enquiries in relation to
the new waste and recycling contract
once again
all costs incurred in providing this
service will be recovered at cost from
warwick district council
and it's expected this will be
formalized through a service level
agreement between the two councils so in
other words what we are doing is we are
working together
to deliver services
where it makes sense and where it says
money
and i don't think we should
underestimate that it is also worth
mentioning that the
delivery of the vehicles
will include logos from both warwick
district and stratfor district because
on this service we actually are working
together
um
the working together program team will
be disbanded because obviously that is
no longer needed
and i would just like to say
how much we appreciate
the work
those people have actually put in it
really was a tremendous effort on their
part
on cctv
we are without a supervisor at the
moment
and despite a great deal of effort
and offering the job of jobs a number of
times we have not got a supervisor so
warwick district will support us
in supervisor for cctv
again
it's one of the
important advantages
of
ending the merger very amicably and i
need to stress that
when it comes to budgets
there is no need for an emergency budget
the reality actually is
that the
additional costs
uh
are in excess of these same savings the
section one five office one officer
believes there is no need for a revised
budget
i would say that the net savings
uh of
from the the
joint working that will continue will be
at least 110 000 a year
there are additional savings from work
joint work on the south warwickshire
local plan
those however are estimated but are
likely to be substantial
sorry
when it comes to internal audit services
we are going to revert to using the
services from
uh
warwickshire county council
so
that basically
is it
they you've got
uh the management team arrangements and
the portfolio
holder alignments
uh
the reality actually is you put in place
an interim structure that will take us
forward
so with that
looking at the
i'm trying to find
looking at and i think it is reasonable
to look at the cabinet minutes because
there were some changes made to the
recommendations this morning
so we have the recommendations
one to six and i'm looking at the
minutes of the cabinet meeting
and in addition
note
items seven and eight
so council i am proposing that we accept
those recommendations on those notes can
i have a second to please
council feeling
thank you very much council fielding for
seconding that
okay
um i open it up to debate
who would like to start
all right that's it thank you very much
indeed it was a very short oh council
rock
uh well thank you chairman i thought
i thought i'd better fill the paws
hadn't i
well
first of all um
uh
members may be aware that um councillors
jefferson and pemberton did do the
courtesy of the lead of the opposition
myself of keeping us informed every step
of the way uh
of what was going on
that's not to say we were involved in
those discussions but we were you know
at least informed
uh regularly as to uh the progress or as
it turned out in the last few days
otherwise of those events i do thank
them for that and i thank the officers
for um an awful lot of hard work that's
gone into it which has turned out to be
i have to apologize members i think if
it happens you'll just turn it try and
turn it off it takes a few seconds turn
it back on again it seems to reset
apologies for this
i've got great i had green flushing
lights and now red again it tells us
something
um
it looks like my interest in a proper
debate consistent with the ones we had
where we went back
has not been
received enthusiastically but um
a couple of points really
this seems to have fallen down on the
due diligence in respect of
not the strategic fit because i think
there was still a strategic fit between
the two authorities it's fallen down on
a really major important detail around
the finance and the due diligence now
those of us that have been in the
private sector wouldn't be at all
surprised to find that these due
diligence things occur when when mergers
go wrong and many of them do go wrong
possibly more go wrong than our
fulfilled
however the due diligence was
recommended
that i kept the file of papers by the
way that we we had and that's it
so i i think it was 161 or something
page 107 of of the report from the lga
that recommended the due diligence
report
uh including uh milwards and homes in
the joint venture
i see the date of that was may
21 so that's a year that's been sitting
there so it's rather
concerning that that's fallen down at
the 11th hour over the easter holidays
and uh i think when the scrutiny
committee looks at that clearly there's
going to be some you know what was
what's gone wrong and the sequence
that's gone wrong uh that that that does
concern me a little bit
uh but because we know we haven't done
that due to this report
we don't
it could have gone it could be okay it
might not be okay we don't know because
we're never going to see the light of
day because of that report because of
whatever machinations have been involved
so i i think that's unfortunate
um
i think you know i i'll sit on the uh
the joint local plan
south foreign uh advisory group and i
think that's been working
pretty well all the bones of that look
like they're working together i'm
slightly concerned about the
caveat the leaders just come up with it
it may not go well right at the end
i accept the bit of reality there but
i'm a bit concerned about that because
there are
many things that have come out of this
that i think we should try and lever
those resources but we've got to ask
ourselves what went wrong i just want to
allude to one other thing that is buried
in there for those of us over in the far
east of the district i see that we're
going to have a joint hs2 liaison
officer
at some future point i would like that
to be explored how it's going to work
with the members
somewhat uh
unfortunately called the 76 over there
in the eastern district is to have that
the eight joint liaison team is going to
work because it's a severe effect both
on warrant justice and on ourselves
and i wouldn't want that to be seen as
some sort of adjunct it's very very
important to
residents over in the east of the
district
thank you very much chairman
thank you very much indeed
okay are there any other speakers
council project
council project was first and then
um well he would have thought we're here
now voting
to unmerge our councils
um feels like the last two years been a
bit of a mirage
um did the council go for a merger to
enhance our democracy was the merger
going to bring residents closer to our
councillors
was this merger going to make wiser
planning decisions
in my mind
probably not so
today's debate is
quite welcome to me because
i didn't support this merger from the
beginning
my feeling is that this merger
really was a cynical ploy
by the leadership
of this council and warwickshire i'm
warwick district council to resolve
a tory party split in warwickshire with
warwickshire county council leader is he
second
i did this leadership become blind to
the reality of the folly of going down
this route for merger
how much money and officer time has been
wasted as a result of this venture
i made strong arguments six months ago
this merger was a bad idea only two
other councillors stood up and voted
against this merger then
this last two years has distracted
officers into moving resources to to
this effort i'm convinced it's had
impacts
on our service to the running of the
council and its residents
i feel this mistake from the beginning
has now damaged the council's reputation
and the organization as a whole
what i find calling are the comments by
tory councillors just six months ago
such as councillor jefferson
saying this is a major strategic
decision the alternative
of unpalatable options of going broke
seeking control of our destiny
this is of national significance
a mandate to improve local government
what are other councils offering as an
alternative
not merging would be unstable for
services
councillor harvey making the argument
may it is a major strategic decision
it enjoys local support
both districts are working well together
and using article two of the
constitution for being in the public
interest
all this based on evidence
council of shenton's passionate plea
uh funding two approaches to climate
change
that the new council
to have pace be agile
we mustn't stand still or we go
backwards
one contract to be to for all um to be
or not to be i believe he said
and councillor jennings um arguments um
both dish both districts on a sound
financial footing i believe he said
spiral of catastrophe if we don't merge
quite strong words
uh multinational companies investing in
a region if we merge
i presume if we don't merge
we'll have the opposite what of what he
was saying
um councillor parry saying if we don't
merge we would be financially
unsustainable
resulting cuts of services inevitable
redundancies i hope uh councillor
jefferson can elaborate on those
comments that she made
councillor parker
saying we must be bold and brave
opportunity of a new housing strategy
will we have a new housing strategy
coming forward now we're not merging
uh councillor pemberton was very
passionate with his speech i remember
um and uh
we were having i think his words were
having resilience to service
councillor dixon saying we were leading
the way in the west midlands
councillor richards may said making
savings and generate new income
so finally if all these toy councils
thought
this to be the next best thing since
sliced bread
are they now saying it's all a bad idea
i know what is a bad idea it's making
this council go through this torturous
merger
with lost money and officer time along
with um
staff morale being affected
i think this whole debacle debaca stinks
to be honest
it's been a bad idea from day one and in
may of next year the electorate will
make a choice on whether they need to
turf out
this
in fact
councillor jefferson should have come
here to apologize today
and perhaps he should resign
thank you council foreign uh council
rolfe
um thank you chair i
was at ovian scrutiny yesterday and took
part
in a very democratic debate where we
were allowed to speak more than once
so that was quite good really um
and
it was
myself who suggested that we have
an independent review on lessons learnt
and uh task and finish group
i see in the notes that a task finish
group for both
sides both warrant district council and
stratfor district council has been
agreed but i strongly recommend that
there is an independent chair
and perhaps we can
ask
one of our independent
ladies and gentlemen ladies or gentlemen
on audit and standards
to be that chair
and partake in the
independence of it thank you very much
thank you cassarov that's rolly hoggins
i am the only member of this council
from any political party or persuasion
that consistently voted against this
merger
there's been two major votes on this and
i am the only one there may have been
people abstaining from the vote but i
was the only one that voted against
i was polite in the way that i did that
and i wrote to tony jefferson and
explained my reasons for that because as
i said in my speeches then this lady was
not for turning
so you can imagine when it was announced
that the merger was off that
perhaps
my colleagues particularly sitting in
front of me
were perhaps quaking their boots ever so
slightly because i'm not one for mincing
my words
but i didn't i didn't go at it with all
guns blazing my attitude was
i was kind and i was kind in the way
that i i dealt with it
which has been mentioned previously
[Music]
that is perhaps our greatest greatest
legacy
because when i was first proposed to
become
an elected member of this council my
part of my interview was that i actually
mentioned the the diabolical waste
collection management systems i had over
there i described it as the benny hill
show really with people running up and
down streets with red boxes so
councillor ian shenson i would like to
thank you probably on behalf of the
warwick lemington
residents that they're no longer going
to have to endure that they will have a
much more efficient system of disposing
of their waste i'm sure they're
grumbling about the green bins as well
but hey people have to grumble about
about something
however what i want to say is this
lessons have been learnt inquiries will
be made and notes will be taken so that
if
if any other council in this great land
of ours decides that they may like to
dip their toe in the water of
amalgamating with another council but we
will be able to offer advice and to look
at
the way that we went about things but i
tell you this the legacy of this council
is that we will now stand proudly once
again as a single district council
working hard for our residents as we
always were and our businesses ensuring
that money isn't wasted and that would
be no longer responsible for the
profligate spending of jaw-dropping
amounts that came to light uh when we
really did
um when when the amounts of money had
been loaned or borrowed by warrick and
lemington came to light
oh you only have to watch the ovied
scrutiny committee meetings from warwick
and lemington council to realize you
know some very difficult questions are
asked there and answers aren't given to
them either
so i'll just i would just like to say
i'm looking forward to this council
getting back on track you may want to
focus on the elections
next may but we are 12 months away from
that we have a great deal to do we have
many residents to work for and i am
still proud to be a conservative
councillor looking forward to the future
and working very hard for our residents
and businesses thank you
thank you counselor
um council cleave
thank you chair um i didn't come with a
pre-prepared speech because i found that
last time where it's supposed to be
prepared which i don't see as as an
actual debate um but my concerns um
councillor feud chick has just
highlighted someone actually counselor
wally hogan's has highlighted some as
well
um i abstained because i was
uncomfortable on both sides however my
concerns right now
as well as for my residents are for the
staff
now i know you're going to address this
i've had one email from a staff member
i've talked to quite a few as a respect
champion
um i've had one email which i'll read a
little bit out if you uh will allow me
um and then i'll ask about that so
it says since the start of the pandemic
we have all had to work from home and as
a council probably worked harder if not
double our workload we would normally do
um
than we would normally do as well as
being guinea pigs for the ever-changing
workplace and the system partly was
driven by the merger
excuse me
the thank you and the appreciation from
higher management has been words and not
actions and there is only a certain
amount of words you can hear until you
do not believe it anymore
this has not been helped by the proposed
merger where it's all been hush hush and
very little openness to the staff even
in the briefings so while it is welcome
to know that something such as the
merger not happening as expected there
is still a certain amount of uncertainty
being being kept in the dark which does
not help anything to the morale
so my question is um
several fold to the staff did any staff
leave
um due to the merger because there was a
certain amount of uncertainty and do we
know yet if they're going to be jobs job
losses which has been briefly mentioned
due to the cancellation of the merger
also what is currently now being done
for the staff to alleviate their stress
because it has been stressful for them
including senior management team which
again we appreciate all the work that
they have done thank you
thank you council
council promise
we will see if this one works whichever
way i could make myself heard as i'm
frequently told in seldom
counsellors as one of the three
councillors that did not vote for this
merger
part of that reason was the lack of
financial clarity
and i expressed this privately to
certain people that i thought financial
figures were being withheld
and obviously i got feeling the reason
why white district council weren't too
keen on due diligence
czech was because of that ultimately
it is right that we find out why as
council rock has mentioned that after a
year that tensions test was never
undertaken
it should have been before we even put
these proposals before us as councillors
that should be a lesson learned for us
in the future
that when it comes to checking on things
let's make sure we also get a diligence
the full picture
but that should be a criticism for us
all as councillors from asking the
questions at the time or highlighting
these issues at the time
it is easy to give recriminations and
say so-and-so said this so-and-so said
that
why suggest to councils instead is that
we know where we are at the moment
but we look how to take this forward
there are reforms we can make a stratfor
district council there is modernization
we can make there were some good ideas
on the steering group that come out
there which we can implement ourselves
i would actually suggest leader
that we
get a new steering group together see
how we do take this council forward
take on those good ideas let's look at
what works well let's look what doesn't
and i would suggest it would be an
opportune time over the next few months
and have something by the end of the
year to discuss the full council
because next year there is an election
coming up and the last thing we want is
new councils coming in
same old problems
we've got an opportunity now
to actually drive ourselves forward
and show that we can survive as a
council
because alternatively we know as part of
this yes a welter unity is still on the
table
i wonder how many residents and how many
councils really want that
there could be other things that come on
the table in the future
but we have to be prepared for all
outcomes and the way to do that is to
prepare ourselves to be the best council
we can be for the 21st century
i've been on this council nearly 10
years now and a lot of things i look
round at times
seem very archaic
and i think we have an opportunity now
to drive forward modernization
and innovation as well and i'm sure
everybody from whatever political
persuasion or independence have all got
some great input on how we drive this
forward and we should start that from
today after this vote and i hope the
leader is going to back this idea and
let's see if we can actually make this
council work and that the residents will
turn around and say you know what
they've done it first and that's why
they're the best
thank you council promise casablanca
thank you councillor bryce
i seem to often end up speaking after
you it
probably amuses both of us equally
um
i do always count since being bold and
brave in decisions
and i think it was bold grave of us in
the first place
the worst strategic imperatives i think
it was also bold and brave of us
to go we've got to have this due
diligence done despite
what was not easy opposition i can
assure you because it had been asked for
i had spent a lot of time
asking for the due diligence on what is
essentially a wholly owned company
milverton homes
um and after
many wrangles
i was given
what was considered at the time to be
chapter and verse on milverton homes
obviously it wasn't
now is now would not be the time for me
in my own personal
and professional life to get involved in
doing a housing development of that sort
so i was feeling moderately queasy
what's really bold and brave is for us
to have gone no
we're not going ahead with this merger
because
hundred million pounds borrowed just
like that with no communication was a
hundred million pounds too far
we do not want to take
our residents into that kind of debt i
can assure you
that until february
and if someone shakes their head because
i've got the wrong month then um
but around february
we had no idea about that and that was
the pretty much the final straw that
pushes the goat look we have got to
discover more
having felt that
things have been transparent up to that
date
so
it's difficult it's unpleasant to sit
here having given two years of my life
not working i know it's working so it's
been really really hard work we've had
to form relationships we've had to do
things extremely differently
as stratfor councillors and we have bent
but in the end
despite the strategic imperative to do
it
we will be better off on our
own no matter what comes at us and as
councillor bromwich says
we are very there are huge changes
potentially coming down the line in
terms of unitary councils
and
the new devo deal we don't know where
that's going or what's happening
but change is afoot whenever it comes
the one good thing and i think my
colleagues in cabinet will probably
agree on this
is that we've come out of this a lot um
personally anyway fitter and more aware
of how to deal with this kind of thing
in local government than we were before
so i certainly feel prepared for what's
coming down the track
and we'll continue
having been quoted jason
to being bouldenburg
thank you
thank you council parker council orcok
thank you chair
um
listening to what's been said so far
raised quite a few questions
for me
i don't understand how we can be better
off going at this on our own when one of
the arguments used to
to help convince council to go along
with this was
if we don't we are going to be in
serious trouble
something there doesn't quite add up
this is not a back slapping look how
well we've got out of this moment
this should be a
we made a grave mistake going into
looking at this and we are sorry
we are sorry to the staff
who have been
made very very unsure on their future
it should be a we're sorry put staff
under that amount of
stress it should be we're sorry
residents
for the uncertainty you've had
and we are sorry
we didn't do things correctly
so the one question i have councillor
jefferson to you
who do you blame in all this
thank you
thank you councillor
uh council pemberton
thank you chairman
so
counselor for check is looking for
an apology
and counsellor councillor alcock
he's
looking to know who he's to blame
so i'm going to give councillor for
check his apology
apologize that i
and this cabinet were convinced and we
were convinced and we still believe that
a strategic level
this was the right thing to do
so the apology is that we've not been
able to pull it off
because there was a prize to be had for
our residents here in stratford and in
warwick to create
a combined district authority
councillor rock
pointed out that in
all areas of life particularly in the
private sector
more mergers don't come off than do
and they often come off the rails for
lots of different reasons
and
there will quite rightly be a task and
finish group of overview and scrutiny
which will look at the
the detail
and i will happily take on the chin
any anything where
part of my decision making can be
seen to have been better i'll take that
on i'll take that on no one's perfect
but everybody went into this
senior politicians in the cabinet senior
officers
trying to build something better
um
and ultimately
when faced with a position where
the landscape for our partner had
changed significantly at a financial
level
and then we asked the questions to try
and get
satisfaction for ourselves for our
members for our residents that this was
still
the best deal for our residents our
members our staff
that when faced with a refusal to answer
that question
we asked for a pause
and that was met with
the deals off so
everybody went through this and
everybody went through it professionally
and we haven't been able to pull it off
and so that's my apology
i know that certain members were against
it councillor wally hoggins uh against
it from day one and has been the epitome
of good grace
uh how as how all this has has come
about um but there is no single person
to blame here councillor orc
um a number of different things have
come into play it will all come out as
far as uh scrutiny is concerned
as far as the staff are concerned
firstly i would i absolutely refute some
of the remarks have been made our senior
officers have worked day and night
and we've had numerous briefings
numerous one-to-ones with staff
yes of course people will be concerned i
got buttonholed in a curry house in
sorry a chinese on friday night in
bedford
okay so it's not universally that people
were always happy with what was going on
but i've been around this building i
speak to officers so do other members
and indeed this cabinet engaged with
senior officers of this council to seek
their views
around what was happening
and
it pains me to say it but there are a
significant number of our officers who
are actually quite pleased that we're
not going down this route because of
what they saw perhaps on the ground as
differences that could not be bridged
and those are the kind of things you
only find out as you get into it so
i'm absolutely backing david and tony
and the rest of the senior management
team they have worked as hard as
possible
to support officers and i know that
individual members not of this council
not just in cabinet but across this
chamber also have done their level best
um so
um i think yes it's been a challenging
time and we've all given two years of
our life to this and i've got battle
scars for it
but
to answer your question going forward
yes
we've got some challenges and we've got
some reconfiguring to do and we've got
some work to do to make this council
move forward to be stronger because
that's what we've got to do that deal's
done dead in the water we have to move
forward and we have to be positive and
we have to find a way
and that's what we're going to try and
do
and that's
you've got my apology and i'll take
criticism for anything that uh any
decision we got wrong but
it was the right thing to start with it
just didn't come off thank you
thank you council council
thank you chair so the sudden collapse
of the merger which has not allowed
counselors to scrutinize
the final due diligence report
shows a breathtaking lack of political
leadership
and a huge amount of rates payer money
and officers time
has been wasted and i'm afraid trust and
confidence in this cabinet
has been broken sadly our residents
would have to wait until the next
election to have their say
in these merger shambles
thank you councilman
council curtis
thank you
chair
i'm confused
i readily
admit that
i'm trying to really understand
what the real reasons are
that lie
behind this collapse
on one hand
we're being told
that and i'm
not trying to apportion any criticism
here but just generally trying to
understand what is going on
on one hand we're being or i'm certainly
getting the impression
that until
february
or thereabouts
everything seemed to be going along
reasonably smoothly
and it was only the emergence
of this additional 100 million
of borrowing
that set in train a sequence of events
that has led to this collapse
i think it is important
the council
does know
the exact date because i've heard
various versions of the precise date
that members
or and or officers became aware
of this additional debt
now at the ov scrutiny meeting yesterday
the chief executive
was at payne's and he reiterated this
several times
the
the emergence of this additional debt
did not mean
that warwick district council was in
dire financial straits
and i think that was made was made very
clear and i think that it's important
that we understand that
but that then obviously triggered the
need for the additional due diligence
so then the sequence rolls on
then we have
milford homes
saying that we needed or they needed a
non-disclosure
agreement
as part of this due diligence process we
understand that that's perfectly
standard but milton holmes then weren't
going to have their board meeting
until i believe it was the 27th of may
but certainly very very close to the
decision date
of the secretary of state
so on one hand
we are being and
because that due diligence couldn't be
completed the leader then felt he had to
write to say
well we then know that the sequence that
followed thereafter
so on one hand we're being told
that the reason that it's all collapsed
is because of
the emergence of this debt or the
additional borrowing
and
the the lack of due diligence around and
if that had been
carried out who knows it may have been
discovered that all was well and the
merger could proceed
but
what confuses me on page 11 in the
appendix one on the proposed merger
there is a significant difference
between the approaches and ambitions of
the two councils
that have proved to be irreconcilable
so on one hand we're being told that
there's an irreconcilable difference
between the two councils and that's why
it's collapsed and on the other hand
we're being told
that because we weren't able to carry
out this due diligence
that's why it's collapsed so as i say
i'm just confused from shotery
i'm also not for the first time baffled
by
the comment
earlier on
from councillor barker
where she says that we're better off on
our own
but how do we know that because the due
diligence hadn't been completed so i
don't honestly think
we are in a better position we are in
the position to know
whether we'd be better off on our own or
in a partnership
as i
i maybe i'm the only one who really
can't get my head around this but there
seem to be so many unanswered questions
one thing i will be doing 30 seconds
please is to watch the warwick district
council
meeting
to try and get a handle on what's said
there because i think that could be
quite informative thank you chair
thank you very much
uh council harvey
um i don't want to
preempt what um council jefferson may
say in his summing up and responding to
the to the debate
um
i think it's pretty clear
i don't share
counselor curtis's confusion perhaps i
have the advantage of certain
information he doesn't
but the the sequence of events
worth it strategically in response to uh
councillor ford checks uh comments uh i
have no doubt that strategically putting
together two councils to form a larger
district council in fact as councillor
rock will know it will have been in
population terms the largest district
council in the country i think there are
economies of scale uh potentially there
to be had
and strategically the influence that a
larger council would have had within the
west midlands would have been
substantial so it is regrettable that it
has come to this
but it has come to this for good reasons
as i see it
yes discussions were going on
and progress was being made
the key factor was warwick's budget
setting
and the issues with warwick's budget
setting as councillor kettle was dying
to tell you
was around we didn't know
about
the additional borrowing during the year
that had been undertaken
we didn't know uh what we did know that
they warrick had to
save substantial sums of money of the
order of 8 million pounds but we're not
at all clear about where that was going
to come from and we were
led to believe that milverton homes
financial contribution in future years
would be crucial to warwick's finances
and yet we had no information in fact we
had
um obfuscation about getting information
in our terms about milverton homes so
the responsible thing to do
was to take stock of changed information
change circumstances and come to a view
and transfer cancel the bromide's point
of view criticism that we didn't
undertake due diligence
last year when it was first raised in
the lga report if we had done that we
would have led to ourselves to the
position of either not doing that due
diligence again at the right and
appropriate time
or doing it twice and paying for it
twice so i'll take no criticism from
councillor bromwich on that particular
point
um
i i come back to my my essential point
i'm sorry that we are in this position
because i saw great potential in in the
merger but we have come to this position
of
change circumstances leading to a need
to re-evaluate and to echo joe barker's
point
it is uncomfortable to have to come to
the decision reluctantly that the facts
mean that you have to change your view
and change your mind and we we took our
point of view and it isn't a shambles in
the way that
councillor pertiguella would refer to it
it was a constructive considered
decision made upon changed information
which led to a what i think is a
sensible decision and when it is
explained to people
they get the message
they really do
thank you jim
thank you very much councillor uh
council kettle
um thank you chairman
um i hadn't realized counselor harvard
was reading my notes at my shoulder i
should be more careful next time um
firstly uh ladies and gentlemen much
references have been made to work by
officers
um which has been
substantial and over and above their
everyday responsibilities in running
this
council uh i therefore firstly like to
propose an amendment resolution to
include within it
our thanks
to mr buckland and his senior and
um
the rest of the rest of the management
team have been involved in this process
for the extraordinary amount of work and
diligence they put into this process
and they as we
will be equally disappointed that the
result has been to move towards a
non-merger than a merger so i'd like to
make that as a proposal
and i'd like to appreciate a seconder
for that
and i like to go on to the debate we've
been having
i'd like to quote the headlines from
last week's stratford-heralds
not about sheep
which is on one side
but about the very first paragraph
the merger is to be scrapped as the
financial risks to stratford residents
were too great
the risks
and we are elected here
to look after the residents of
stratford and therefore it is imperative
that we understand what those risks or
do our very best to understand what
those risks are
and therein lie the problem we faced
uh at the end of march at the beginning
of april
firstly to councillor pertiguella
there was no final report if you've got
a copy of it perhaps you might look
sharing with us because nobody has seen
a copy of any final report because it
was not written
because the report could not be
completed
because we were not allowed access or
the reporting accountants were not
allowed access
to the financial records of milverton
homes
until a date long past the decision had
been confirmed by the secretary of state
now that was due after the recent
election
the juju report would have taken some
four weeks to complete we knew the first
date
sometimes
still not working right
which microphone am i going to use
they're sort of breeding on my desk
um
but that work done before the 13th
enabled us to have a much better idea
about the formal requirements that we
needed to instruct the accountants to
to work towards
so it wasn't as though nothing was
happening during that period huge
amounts of work was being done to
understand not what we knew but what we
didn't know
and once we knew what we didn't know and
so to speak we could then instruct those
reporting accountants to look at those
areas
so it wasn't a matter of starting from a
standing start sometime after the 30th
of december that work had been going on
for months
however we were not in a position to
formally
appoint people to do that work until we
had approval from this council which we
eventually got
council curtis you turned around about
um saying you're confused i'm sorry
about that uh 30 seconds we'll carry on
uh
there doesn't have to be one reason
mergers are all about risk of reward
balancing the upsides of the downsides
what became apparent was there there
were other concerns that rose as well
but the key issue was
we have to look after the benefits of
stratford district council council
taxpayers and the risk we were unable to
assess because we were not allowed to be
given access to one of the key risk
areas um within warwick district council
finances thank you mr chairman thank you
very much indeed council 30 guys do you
have a point of order
yes the point of order so i meant yes we
couldn't scrutinize the final report
because that was never um finished or
completed
that was my point so we don't know
that's that's actually it's not quite a
point of order it is it's an elaboration
on something but fair enough
um i think we get the
the point thank you very much councilman
okay uh next council franchisee jenny
uh thank you i think my microphone's
working um
can i say that as liberal democrats so
we've always supported uh shared
services with other councils to uh make
ourselves more efficient and uh to keep
council tax as low as possible and
services i'm sure
i mean they have been uh
shared they are being shared and they
will be shared in the future
my support to explore this political
merger was very much based in
democratic representation
a larger union now is actually on the
table a warwickshire union which is
actually going to take i fear
uh the relationship between the decision
maker and those that pay council tax and
make that
that line longer more obscure and more
difficult for residents
to cope with
and
from the discussion we've just been
having about due diligence have it
having it taken place when it took
when we go into the
discussions on
the last i do apologize for this members
it is uh painful for all as i'm sure you
please you put me off your thought
process i do apologize council franchise
when we as i presume at some point in
the future be asked to look at this much
larger merger having learnt lessons from
what we've been through now uh could be
useful in that process
but
there will be other things to be looking
at there and what really concerns me
is this lack of democratic
representation for our residents thank
you
thank you council
uh council junaid
yes it's been referred to many times
about lessons learned and that we should
we have to learn
uh and and that was an emphasis
i i think quite honestly um what has
happened here with these microphones is
that the somebody has not charged up the
battery of infills properly
so
please i hope that doesn't occur again
it is very interesting indeed to read
back with hindsight the original lga
financial review and i'm not even sure
that an awful lot of counsellors
actually read it
word for word and and in depth
because
it it did present quite a few questions
that the task and finish group and the
ovian scrutiny committee does need to
look at it was very straightforward
about the differences between the two
councils both in culture and in finances
it had it it did outline the similar
risk profiles of the councils and the
different uh the exposures
to changes in government funding with
the resources reducing over time
dispatch despite council tax increases
and over reliance on new homes bonus and
the fees and charges income
and that's something that we have to
look forward to not only lessons learned
but in the
finances going forward of this council
because one of the crucial things that
this that was looked at for the reasons
for going through this merger was the
finances as i understand it if i
remember correctly
it was something like 1.275 million a
year savings were eventually expected
from the merger and we do have to take
that into consideration particularly if
we get yet another one-year settlement
going forward
so that's that was that was one thing it
was noted about the um that the
differences in the capital investment
program and the borrowings planned
and the loans for the housing company
were highlighted and i recommend review
recommended uh and um you know i know
the the difficulties later on but it was
recommended and again that was one of
the things that was of interest because
um this council has the biggest housing
waiting list in warwickshire
and housing affordable housing is a
really serious problem for this district
and it's one of the things that again i
would like to have looked at as we go
forward whatever the outcome it would
have needed to be go
be handled uh and we do need that uh to
be handled
it looked at
that original review say looked at um
that
the economic resilience the economist of
scale it looked at the higher
lower levels of reserves of one councils
versus the other the higher level of
pension deficit one council versus the
other uh and a whole raft of other
things
one of the things that it recommended
was that they should be going forward
throughout the whole period should be
that there should be a shadow merged
savings plan and that it should be kept
up to date and reviewed regularly
the other thing that was recommended was
that there should be strong political
management
and it said and i am quoting here the
leadership of both councils
to making
um to making the merger happen and i do
hope questions are asked whether that
was the case if it is then it was the
case fine but if it wasn't then that is
something that
does need to be looked at
it also recommended in that original
report that there should be clear
arrangements in place
to look at the key milestones in the pro
process
and that we should at the end look at
whether or not there was a sufficiently
clearly
thought out program of work with
rational granular savings targets and a
ruthless focus on financial benefit
delivery
so these were parts of that original
report and i do hope that they will
therefore be key parts of the review and
the lessons learned as well as answering
those extra questions that i have about
whether or not we can make need to make
up the the finance and the housing uh
through the route re
and can i all ask that on those services
where we are to share that we again
review those because for example i do
know that stratfor district council has
taken over the contact services for um
warwick district council it does need to
be made sure that we are delivering on
that not only for our residents but
because it is a service level agreement
with warwick and i know that councillor
cargo will know that the town council at
ulster has had a lot of references with
people saying they cannot get through to
the sa to the uh contact service uh and
how to deal with that so i do hope that
that is reviewed as well okay thank you
very much thank you
thank you
uh cancer crumb
thank you mr chairman and
probably unfortunately for the meeting
the the microphone is working
and i did smile that uh as a farmer that
uh councillor kettle's microphones were
breeding so i thought that was that was
that was quite tough
but but moving on um having worked at
warwick district council for 30 plus
years and straight from school of course
um i still have contacts there
and i've been told that while staff that
both wdc and sdc have had good job and
merger concerns
they had been well supported by both
unison branches who were in regular
contact with
uh senior management who again gave
very full and thorough briefings on a
regular basis
so
well done to all those concerned in that
obviously we've still got the benefits
ongoing regarding the buffer contract
the southwesterly local plan that some
of us run and are still on and the safe
workshop economic development strategy
as well which is again i think is very
beneficial
we've we've had the tuscan finish group
on the south build
and again that was useful and again it
was helpful that we had offices both
from stratford district and warwick
district to make that a thorough and
robust
uh review and we came out with some good
work
and again we've uh
in deference to
mr grafton there we've had the lgi code
of conduct
discussions and again involving officers
uh councillors
and independent people both from stc and
wdc and again that was a robust review
of the code of
conduct um when as a member of osc again
i have questioned
uh at meetings and i think mr buckland
was probably fed up with hearing me
saying it about the capacity of senior
staff to do all the day jobs as well as
the merger and obviously we were told
that 100k been put aside by by both
councils to to cover that
um so yeah have i been a total fan of
this
you know
sort of
slightly yeah yes in favor because i
could see the benefits
but there was always caveats but again i
was willing to listen and wait and look
at the evidence that came out in front
of me and the evidence i've seen
recently
seems to justify the fact that we
shouldn't be carrying on with this
um
obviously as ex-chair of uh audits and
standards uh lots of things we talked
about eeg the lga code of conduct
and i'd like to stay as as the new
elected chair of oversea that any review
on lessons learned and preventing such a
position occurring any task and finish
group
uh will be robust thorough
challenging have attention to the detail
and as far as i'm concerned i'm sure
cancer junior does vice chair will agree
as well it will have clear terms of
reference
and i think that is important
and again
i have an open mind
to the makeup of this group not my
makeup but the makeup of this group
so i think the tuscan finish group
mentioned that chair by council iraq on
self build was an example
of how such a group could work
and i think i've got no qualms about
having this task and finished group
about the lessons learned
and
the the report will be thorough and in
detail if it's agreed that we can do
that so thank you
thank you council
uh council dixon
thank you chairman i don't think i
missed it but uh my understanding uh of
the circumstances that led to this
decision
was whereby
we as district council
wanted
the decision by the secretary of state
to be postponed
so that
and
arms lengths
are we on again right
my understanding was that uh essentially
councilor jefferson
uh in discussions with his councillor
day uh wanted to have a situation
whereby
rather than have the secretary of state
making the decision before the due
diligence could be completed
we would ask for a postponement
so that due diligence could be completed
in accordance with the time scales of an
arms length organization which wasn't
due to mutating until the end of may
now if there was some urgency about this
matter um i would have thought if it was
a wholly owned uh property company of
warwick district council though i
understand there might be a minor
shareholder somewhere in there there is
a situation whereby
an extraordinary meeting could have been
called
not so
so essentially
my understanding is that council today
more or less said we aren't agreeable to
postponement
we're not agreeable to a situation
whereby you can get your due diligence
and therefore
we will object to you as it were calling
off this merger by writing to the
secretary of state
so i don't think it was our reluctance
to go forward
it was warwick's district council's
reluctance to allow a small postponement
and if that postponement had been agreed
six weeks eight weeks perhaps for that
uh due diligence to be completed we may
indeed have heard from the uh
investigators that due diligence was
fine that the numbers had changed since
the initial uh review of warwick
district council but nevertheless those
other numbers had changed
they were still financially sound
virtually okay and we could all go ahead
but that opportunity was not given to us
because white district council said
we are not prepared to wait
and i think that is a great shame
because i think a merger of the two
would have been a super
improvement in the west midlands thank
you chairman
thank you casa i have cancer fielding
next
you chair
um i'd like to underline what counselor
kettle and councillor barker have done
with regards to the voters thanks to the
staff particularly
the living on my own it is
joined the pandemic to see members of
the
member services who would appear and to
talk to and get a little bit of
reassurance to other members of the
management team
occasionally getting killed off um
which
i think david barker is well aware of
buckland sorry
my apologies getting the wrong person
but i thank you so much for all your
help support i would love to see the
planning officers back
upstairs
uh it is so much
better to understand what they're say
talking to them when you can go through
plans on
the table
but anyway many thanks
thank you counselor i have no more hands
up
i know tony has the right to reply i'm
sure he will want to say that i did
mr chairman
as i understood it councillor kettle's
proposal was to add a number eight
uh
beyond data number nine thanking the
staff which i'm expecting everybody to
agree with but i believe that's what
we're about to um
to vote on i see officers nodding and
and i think when we get to it we would
we would like to
take the items one by one chairman when
we get to that point but i i personally
i just wanted to clarify we've got a
number a number nine which i think we're
probably all going to agree with but uh
just want to be clear what we're doing
because an amendment was proposed
that's fine hold on
yeah if we could do it in this sequence
that we just accept the amendment first
and then
we
take that point about
dealing with the separate votes and you
need a seconder for that
council jefferson would you like to
start
i would indeed share thank you
um
very interesting here what council of
fighting said about this being a cynical
ploy
far from it
if you actually look at the situation we
were in in mid-2020
i mean the situation for the council
looked dire
we were looking at a deficit of eight
and a half million
caused predominantly by covid
we believe that when we got the annual
settlement at the end of 2020
that
we would lose all the new homes bonus
and there would be a reset
of business rates
the reality actually was at that point
in time
things looked bleak
if we actually looked then
at the opportunities provided by merger
not only were there cost savings to be
gained
but there was increased influence
a bigger role to play in the west
midlands
and i have to say
that over the time we have been working
together
that has actually manifested itself for
real
there was also the opportunities that
will be provided by the fact that
warwick district council had a housing
revenue account and had a development
subsidiary
so at that point
to be quite honest
from my point of view and from cabinet's
point of view the interests of our
residents
and let's be honest that's what drives
us the interests of our residents
would be best served by pursuing the
merger
i make no apologies for that
i think it was the right decision at the
time
under the circumstances
it was a major strategic decision
it certainly at that time did not
seem to be a folly
so
we then look at
is that better
i think my colleagues councillor harvey
and councillor kettle have covered
adequately
the issues around due diligence
there is absolutely no point in doing
due diligence until you've got the
latest information
and we got that with the publication of
the warwick district council budgets
i think to be precise on the 28th of
february this year
i think there was
there should have been
a lot of work done
on putting together joint savings
budgets
and
also a joint picture on reserves
that work was never completed and that
was a problem
and i think that was down to the joint
section 151 officer being overloaded
uh
i pick up the point that councillor
wally hoggins made
about the west contract being a good
legacy
i think it is
it is something that i think we can
justifiably be proud of
it has no doubt about it saved money
i take the point that there will be work
to do with the contact center to make
sure it all works properly but
nevertheless
we have one worse contract covering two
districts
had we actually tried to do it for one
district
there is no doubt about it it would have
cost us more
and we may well not have got that many
people bidding for it
okay it doesn't matter how or when you
go through a merger process
it is going to be stressful and it is
going to be uncertain
that comes with the territory councillor
clave
and
i would say
that
having been through mergers
the reality actually is they are complex
they are messy
they are not straightforward
and the reality is you're dealing with
people
you're dealing with different cultures
and in a sense
you're on a journey
and you know broadly where you're
heading but you don't necessarily know
the details
so
i turned to tony bromage's points
lack of financial clarity that was one
of the curses
around
the last few months of last year
i was no doubt about that and tried to
get financial clarity i have to say it
was not for the want of trying
and i would wholly agree
it's all now about taking us forward
we have gained a lot of knowledge
from going through the process
in particular i think we have gained
an awful lot from the way cabinet has
worked together and the way kevin has
worked with the senior officers
and i think i would actually say i would
commend our senior office as being a for
being a particularly good team
and we've seen that throughout the
process
uh
i pick up the point that what councilor
barker said
it is it was really hard work
this was not easy
and we did everything we could to make
it work
uh
i
can emphasize with
councillor curtis's confusion
but the reality actually is that when
you see the facts changing
you should change your mind
would people have carried on
blindly
the answer should be no
in terms of the dates
i would just say that on the 2nd of
february actually interestingly enough
before the budget was
published
we requested a refresh of the financial
due diligence
that was on the background timeline that
mr brookland has gone through
both in the presentation to counselors
last week and yesterday to the overview
and scrutiny committee
so
if we move on to the points that
counselor jenny fragile made
the reality actually is the prospect of
a single unitary may not be closer
i would have to agree with her about
the fact
that the
democratic
i think a two unitary solution for
warwickshire would be far better than a
single unitary because it combines both
scale and is closer to residents
uh useful lessons learned
i think there are
mergers are not easy
um
moving on to what councillor june had
said yes there are lessons that will be
learned
it is interesting that the initial
report
from the lga officers said there were no
show stoppers
we tried very hard as i said earlier to
get a shadow merged savings plan
and it was not delivered
we have put time and energy into it and
i think it's right the political
situation at warwick district council
did not help
where there was not an overall majority
it made life difficult
and i think that is one of the things
that perhaps we underestimated
so
all i will say is
i think we took the right decision when
we started the merging process and we
took that decision in the clear
interests of our residents as we saw it
at the time
and i think when in reality
we triggered the end of the process we
took the right decisions
for our residents so i make no apologies
for what we've done
i think we took the right decision to
start with and the right decision at the
end thank you
thank you um council do you need your
appointed border
just whether or not
the the vote is to be taken
one by one or
yes we are going to take it one by one
okay um
no
mr buckland would you like to just
explain
thank you chairman there was
eight recommendations that came forward
from the cabinet this afternoon and
that's now been an additional
recommendation that's coming um been
made this afternoon in relation to a
vote of thanks to all staff in relation
to their support to the merger process
what i would suggest is that becomes the
new recommendation seven
and actually those are numbers seven and
eight which were for donating and there
was discussion yesterday at the osc so
hopefully that the wording of how the
recommendations are shown is in support
of members there that we then take um
eight the seven becomes eight and eight
and become nine um but yes chairman
there's therefore seven recommendations
for decision by council
thank you
um i have counselor kettle
did
propose this
um i've got a
draft which i'm going to hand over to
him
of a format that may
suit him or not
and if he wishes to amend that as fine
as part of your proposal
otherwise
we're going to carry on now for the
vote on the recommendations individually
so the first recommendation item one
is that the formal submission to the
department for leveling up housing and
communities to create a south
warwickshire district council be
withdrawn
all those in favor
please raise your
all those against
are we actually going to be asked to go
through a series of people just
abstaining
oh
guys you've got to make a decision
thank you thank you members that is now
carried
item two the work that work on the full
service integration of teams across
stratford-on-avon and warwick district
councils be terminated all those in
favor
thank you all those against
any abstentions
council project thank you
that is carried that work on the
identification of sharing civic and
office accommodation between stratford
or navon and warwick district council be
terminated
all those in favor
oh hold on
cancer could i ask a clarification on
this are there any other options on the
table at the moment that we don't know
about that not that we're aware of but
it's well worth bringing it forward if
you feel that there's something else to
do
let's carry on with that vote please all
those in favor
all those against
abstentions
that's lost but it's carried thank you
that a review of the constitution be
undertaken to remove the following
committees and groups the joint
appointments committee the joint
appointments subcommittee joint
arrangement steering group and to
transfer the terms of reference from
both committees back to the employment
committee all those in favor
carried
item five that the arrangements for the
joint management team be terminated from
the 12th of may 2022 and that the
interim management team structure be
noted
all those in favor
all those against
abstentions
that's carried thank you
item six that changes to the officer
scheme of delegations as in a
consequence of the transfer of service
functions between chief officers be
approved by council as shown the
appendix for to the agenda report as
amended
thank you as long as everyone's aware of
the amendment to that one all those in
favor
that's carried thank you
now council kettle do you wish to
read out your proposal your motion of
thanks please
thank you mr chairman
um the proposal stands as follows
this council wishes to press its sincere
thanks to the senior management team and
all those staff involved who have worked
so very hard in trying trying to achieve
this merch merger
all right we have a second joe account
of are you happy with that
in that case i will ask for a
all the agreement with that
that's unanimous and thank you so much
for that and i'm sure that will be
greatly received by the staff as well
thank you
the other two items my eight and nine
now
are for noting only
thank you very much indeed
i am not aware of any urgent business
i'm sorry i apologize i've got the wrong
agenda here
apologies let's go on to the next one
calendar of meetings thank you
uh to consider recommendation from the
audit and standards committee is
contained in minute 718 of its meeting
held on the 27th of april 2022 i invite
councillor crump
as chairman of the audit and standards
committee to introduce the report
thank you mr chairman um
i note your need for speed
so i'll keep this very brief
uh this has been brought about
as part of the demerger where we were
trying to
coincide coordinate
uh meetings with warwick district
council
so therefore basically uh we discussed
this in detail at the audit status
committee
uh the other week 27th of april
so therefore there is a new calendar of
meetings which is attached to the agenda
and basically we will be facilitating
the changes namely four council meetings
uh have reverted to the monday avoiding
school holidays
and the scheduled time of cabinet
meetings has reverted to monthly
and obviously the own overview and
scooter meetings have remained on a
friday immediately before the monday
meeting in the cabinet in order to give
members of that committee more time to
view and consider the cabinet reports
hopefully it's not do you have a
seconder for this
council mills
thank you
uh
council cleave
thank you chair um could i just ask
do we have will we reset times because
one of these things the dates i always
put in the calendar they're always there
but i know we've had lots of recent
changes with times once the times are
set will they be set
thank you
chairman thank you it's always the
part of the business of the first
meeting of every uh cap committee to
determine the start time of their
meetings for the coming year so be up to
the committee to determine that decision
thank you
any other queries on that
if not um
the proposals be made
is that are we all in agreement
agreed thank you
uh right last item urgent business none
to date
therefore i am close to the meeting and
thank you very much indeed for my first
speaking it didn't make it too difficult
for me thank you
you